WE WILL BREAK IN.
I'M TRACE GALLAGHER.
NOW BACK TO "HANNITY."
♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, COME AS WE
CONTINUE TO BROADCAST, SO SUNNY
CALIFORNIA, THE HIGHEST TAXED
STATE IN THE COUNTRY, FOR THE
HOUR, WE CONTINUE WITH
CALIFORNIA GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE CAITLYN JENNER.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME GET TO THIS
ISSUE.
ON THE ISSUE OF GIRLS,
TRANSGENDER SPORTS, CREATED A
CONTROVERSY, THAT WAS
INTERESTING TO ME, AND YOUR
COMMENTS TO JOY BEHAR, WE HAVE
BIGGER PROBLEMS --
>> Caitlyn: YES.
>> Sean: THEN PRONOUNS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JOY BEHAR AND I AGREE ON
NOTHING, BUT I THOUGHT THAT WAS
VERY GRACIOUS OF YOU AND I
AGREED WITH YOU.
I DON'T THINK SHE DID IT ON
PURPOSE.
>> Caitlyn: NO, MOST
PEOPLE -- MY MOTHER, SOMETIMES S
ME.
BY THE WAY, MY MOTHER, SHE WAS,
DURING WORLD WAR II, SHE WAS IN
IT INSPECTOR FOR AIRCRAFT, I
LOVE HER TO DEATH, SHE IS LIVING
IN IDAHO.
MY MOTHER LOVES YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
WATCHES YOU EVERY NIGHT.
NO, SHE WATCHES YOU EVERY NIGHT,
CALLS ME AFTER THE SHOW TO
DISCUSS EVERYTHING ON "HANNITY."
SO, IN TEN DAYS, SHE TURNS 95.
>> Sean: I'M CALLING MOM.
>> Caitlyn: HER NAME IS
ESTHER.
>> Sean: OKAY.
>> Caitlyn: FOR A QUICK TO THE
CAMERA, HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
>> Sean: OF COURSE.
ESTHER, HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
GOD BLESS YOU.
AND YOU ARE SMART, YOU ARE IN
IDAHO.
AND KAITLYN IS PAYING -- BY THE
WAY, I'M DONE, I'M IN NEW YORK.
CAITLYN IS IN CALIFORNIA.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, YOU ARE IN OUR
LOVE, THOUGHTS, AND PRAYERS.
>> Caitlyn: SHE WILL GO CRAZY
ON THAT ONE.
ANYWAY, I JUST HAD TO DO THAT.
>> Sean: GIRLS, TRANSGENDER
SPORTS, PEOPLE THAT, LIKE JOY,
SAY THE WRONG THING.
>> Caitlyn: I MENTIONED A
SECOND AGO, MY MOM SOMETIMES,
SHE GOT SUBSETS, I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THE COMMUNITY HAS A BIGGER
PROBLEM WITH THAT THAN I DO.
I STICK WITH MY STATEMENTS THAT
I MADE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE INTEGRITY OF GIRLS
SPORTS IS THERE.
I THINK THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
BUT IT'S -- THERE'S MORE TO IT
THAN JUST WHAT I SAID, BECAUSE I
JUST SAID BIOLOGICAL BOYS IN
SPORTS.
THERE'S MORE TO IT THAN THAT.
I THINK I'M IN THE FUTURE, I
WILL EXPLAIN MORE OF THAT, BUT
FOR ME, AS A TRANS WOMAN, I
THINK ROLE MODELS ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
TRANS ISSUES, PEOPLE STRUGGLE
WITH BIG TIME.
OUR SUICIDE RATE IS NINE TIMES
HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
AND FOR ME TO BE A ROLE MODEL
FOR THEM, TO BE OUT THERE, I AM
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHO WOULD HAVE EVER THUNK THAT?
WE'VE NEVER EVEN HAD A WOMAN
GOVERNOR.
>> Sean: BUT SOME ARE MAD AT
YOU.
>> Caitlyn: THAT'S -- I
DON'T -- I MOVE ON.
I WANT TO BE ABLE ROLE MODEL,
AND TO BE A LEADER.
AND I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING AS A LEADER THAT YOU CAN
DO IS YOUR COMPASSION, YOUR
HONESTY, AND I THINK THAT
SOMETIMES IT'S VERY LACKING.
IN POLITICS.
SO, I WANT TO BE AN EXAMPLE TO
ALL PEOPLE, NOT JUST TRANS
PEOPLE, BUT THIS --
>> Sean: FLY ON THE SPORTS
SIDE OF IT, THOUGH?
HOW YOU CAME DOWN ON THE SPORTS
SIDE OF THE ISSUE.
>> Caitlyn: I DON'T KNOW
WHY -- TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, I
DON'T KNOW WHY, WHY DO YOU
THINK, SEAN, THEY KEEP ASKING ME
THAT QUESTION?
>> Sean: GREAT QUESTION.
>> Caitlyn: IT IS A GOOD
QUESTION.
THERE IS MORE PROBLEMS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAN
THAT.
>> Sean: WELL, UNDERSTOOD.
THERE ARE.
I WANT TO GET INTO --
>> Caitlyn: HONESTLY, SEAN.
MY ISSUES, I'M STANDING ON MY
BACK PORCH A COUPLE YEARS AGO,
I'M WATCHING 200-FOOT PLANES
COME IN, COMING UP THE HILL AT
ME.
WHY?
17 MILES AWAY, IN CHATSWORTH, A
TRANSFORMER BLEW.
A FEW HOURS LATER, TRAVELED
17 MILES, I HAD TO EVENTUALLY
EVACUATE MY HOUSE, IT WAS SO
INTENSE.
WE HAD NOT HAD A BURN THERE IN
35 YEARS, IT WAS SO INTENSE.
WE NEED TO UPDATE OUR GRID, OUR
ELECTRICAL SYSTEM.
I THINK THAT IS A POSITION, WE
WORK WITH THE ELECTRICAL
COMPANIES AND SACRAMENTO.
I DON'T THINK SACRAMENTO AND THE
TAXPAYER SHOULD DO ALL OF THAT,
THEY ARE ALREADY PLAYING ENOUGH.
>> Sean: THESE ROLLING
BLACKOUTS, LIKE WILDFIRES --
>> Caitlyn: ROLLING BLACKOUTS,
I PUT A GENERATOR IN MY HOUSE,
EVERY TIME THE WIND BLOWS, THEY
ARE AFRAID SOME SYSTEM WILL
SPARK AND START A FIRE.
WHEN I STOOD THERE WATCHING THIS
FIRE COME AT ME, I NEVER SAW --
I LOVE THE FIRE DEPARTMENT, I
LOVE THESE GUYS THAT ARE OUT
THERE, BUT WHEN IT WAS COMING IN
MY HOUSE, I NEVER SAW ONE
HELICOPTER, I NEVER SAW ONE FIRE
TRUCK, I DIDN'T EVEN HEAR A
SIREN.
GRANTED, I LIVE IN A MORE RURAL
AREA AND THEY WERE PROBABLY OVER
PROTECTING MORE HOUSES, BUT WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB, WE NEED
AN EARLY DETECTION SYSTEM WHEN
IT COMES TO FIRE.
I SEE SO MANY OF THEM IN MALIBU,
I LIVED THERE FOR 48 YEARS, AND
THE BIGGEST THING IN THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THAT THEY
JUMP ON A FIRE AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE AND PUT IT OUT WHEN IT
IS SMALL.
AND ONCE IT GETS AWAY FROM THEM,
THEY CAN'T.
>> Sean: WOULD YOU ALLOW
CONTROLLED BURNS?
>> Caitlyn: YES.
>> Sean: ISN'T THERE A SCIENCE
BEHIND FORESTRY?
IS THAT SCIENCE BEING IGNORED IN
THE STATE?
>> Caitlyn: YES.
>> Sean: I LIVE IN
SANTA BARBARA, I WATCHED HOME
BRANCH BURNED DOWN AFTER I JUST.
>> Caitlyn: MANAGEMENT IS
EXTREME IMPORTANCE.
IT IS NOT EVEN FOREST
MANAGEMENT, MY HOUSE, THE REASON
MY HOUSE MADE IT IS BECAUSE THEY
SAY YOU HAVE TO KEEP ANY BRUSH
50 OR 75 FEET -- I THINK I HAD
75 FEET CLEARANCE.
IN THE FIRES CAME, THEY JUST
WENT AROUND MY HOUSE SO FAST, IT
WAS GONE, BECAUSE IT IS MOVING
VERY FAST.
SO IT IS ALL MOST THE SAME THING
FOR FOREST MANAGEMENT, JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF PREPARATION, YOU
KNOW, AND MY HOUSE MADE IT.
BUT FIVE HOUSES AROUND ME WERE
BURNED TO THE GROUND, LIVES WERE
DESTROYED.
>> Sean: WE NOW WENT THROUGH
THIS -- THIS WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC.
VERY HUGE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN,
SAY, RED STATES, FLORIDA,
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY IF YOU WERE THE
GOVERNOR, WITH COVID-19?
>> Caitlyn: FIRST OF ALL,
GAVIN NEWSOM COME ON THIS ISSUE,
HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE.
OKAY?
HE'S USED IT AS A POLITICAL TOOL
IN THE STATE, TO SHUT IT DOWN,
TO CONTROL PEOPLE, AND THAT
SHOULD NOT HAPPEN.
HE'S DESTROYED BUSINESSES.
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES WERE
DESTROYED.
RESTAURANTS DESTROYED.
NOT BEING ABLE TO OPEN UP.
HE SHOULD'VE DONE A BETTER JOB.
I DON'T BLAME ANYONE, BACK IN
MARCH OF 2020, I DON'T BLAME THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, FOR COMING
DOWN AND SAYING "WE ARE GOING TO
SHUT THIS COUNTRY DOWN BECKLEY,"
AND THEY DID.
BUT I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HAD
ANY IDEA HOW IT WAS GOING TO BE
A POLITICAL GAME TO REOPEN.
AS YOU SAID, SOME STATES HAVE
DONE VERY WELL, MENTIONED
FLORIDA.
WE'VE DONE A TERRIBLE JOB.
EASY EXAMPLE.
FLORIDA, ORLANDO, DISNEY WORLD,
OPENED UP NINE MONTHS AGO.
ANAHEIM, DISNEYLAND, OPENED UP
SIX DAYS AGO.
WE ARE TALKING NINE MONTHS OF
SHUTTING DISNEYLAND DOWN.
WHEN IT DID NOT HAVE TO BE SHUT
DOWN.
AND THE LIST OF THAT GOES OVER
AND OVER AND OVER, AND JUST ITS
TOTAL MISMANAGEMENT OF THIS
PROCESS.
>> Sean: WOULD YOU COME IF YOU
HAD TO PICK GOVERNORS IN THE
COUNTRY, BECAUSE LIKE NEW YORK,
NEWSOM, WHITMER, MURPHY, WOLF,
THEY HAD EXECUTIVE ORDERS FOR
NURSING HOMES, WHICH PEOPLE
DON'T SEEM TO TALK ABOUT, ARE
THERE TWO OR THREE GOVERNORS
THAT YOU THINK ARE DOING A GREAT
JOB AT YOU IF YOU BECOME
GOVERNOR --
>> Caitlyn: TEXAS IS DOING A
GREAT JOB.
HONESTLY, I WOULD'VE COORDINATED
WITH THOSE PEOPLE.
TALKING, WHAT IS WORKING FOR
YOU, WHAT IS NOT WORKING FOR
YOU?
IT BECOMES -- AND I LOOK AT THE
SUCCESSFUL ONES -- THEY HAVE ALL
BEEN A COLLABORATION BETWEEN
PRIVATE BUSINESS AND GOVERNMENT.
>> Sean: WOULD YOU OPEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COMPLETELY
TOMORROW?
>> Caitlyn: ABSOLUTELY.
OPEN IT RIGHT UP.
ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW WHAT --
>> Sean: JUST DON'T CLOSE
IN-N-OUT BURGER BEFORE I LEAVE.
>> Caitlyn: IT IS KIND OF ON A
SMALL-SCALE WORKING ALREADY.
ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO, IT WAS
RUMORED, RIGHTFULLY SO, IT WAS
RUMORED THAT I WAS LOOKING TO
RUN FOR GOVERNOR.
THE NEXT DAY, GAVIN NEWSOM HAS A
PRESS CONFERENCE, SAYS THE STATE
IS OPENING UP JULY 15TH.
I'M LAYING THERE IN BED AND
WATCHING THIS, AND I SAY, YES,
IT'S ALREADY WORKING.
YEAH.
>> Sean: OH, BY THE WAY COME
HE IS BLAMING THIS RECALL ON CUE
IN ON, ANTI-FAXERS, AND
ANTI-IMMIGRATION CITIZENS.
>> Caitlyn: I AM PRO-ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> Sean: PRO-ILLEGAL
>> Caitlyn: LEGAL IMMIGRATION,
YES, PRO-ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
SORRY, DID I MISS THE LEGAL
PART?
THAN